the more compute we get the less
efficient we have to be with it the less
compute costs the more incentive we have
to be inefficient because we can spend
our time on other things and so it's
absolutely right that in times when Mo's
law is improving at a rapid Pace
software Engineers try less hard to be
efficient but I guess when I look at the
explosion of interest in applications of
AI over just the past couple of years it
seems to me that there's a lot of pretty
fantastic products coming down the
pipeline and to me that's a sign that
we're finding new applications for more
law and it's only because of mors law
that you're able to train big AI systems
because they're just so data intensive
and therefore just so compute intensive
to train